This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个iHeart播客。Guaranteed Human。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）为你带来的《艰难一课》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个空间聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都觉得不太安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一位知悉其道的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人带着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做，收听
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难一课》。2%。这是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇异的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即TWO%，可在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个高产的诈骗犯约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
收听《闺蜜们。相信我，宝贝》，在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回顾往事》（Look Back at It）播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重大时刻。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spike and welcome back to the Psychology of Your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Before we get into it, I want to let you guys know that this episode and the psychology of your 20s is now on Netflix.
和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾往事》。大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克（Gemma Speake），欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个我们探讨20多岁时最大的改变、时刻和过渡期，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。在我们深入探讨之前，我想告诉大家，这一集以及《20多岁的心理学》现在已经登陆Netflix了。
That is a wild thing to say, but it is true. If you want to watch the video version of this podcast and you are in the US or Canada, you can go to Netflix right now, look up the psychology of your 20s and you will see my face and you will see our podcasts. It goes without saying it is such an honor and I'm truly so grateful to you all that you have given me this opportunity. The entire feel, the vibe is incredible. I think it's so personal. It brings a whole new element to it. And if you want to feel like you are sitting in your living room, in my living room, with me, having a chat, now is your opportunity. Go to Netflix, look up the psychology of your 20s.
说出这句话感觉太疯狂了，但这是真的。如果你想观看这个播客的视频版本，并且你身在美国或加拿大，你现在就可以打开Netflix，搜索《20多岁的心理学》，你就会看到我的脸，也会看到我们的播客。这是不言而喻的，这真的是莫大的荣幸，我真的非常感谢大家给了我这个机会。整个感觉，氛围简直不可思议。我觉得它太私人了。它带来了一种全新的元素。如果你想感觉自己正坐在你的客厅里，在我的客厅里，和我一起聊天，现在就是你的机会。去Netflix，搜索《20多岁的心理学》。
I'd love to see you over there. But without further ado, let's get into the episode. Hello, everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we break down the psychology. of our 20s. Just a heads up, today's episode will be naturally covering topics like sex, sexual assault and other mature themes, but also difficult themes. So if this is something you may find
我很乐意在那里见到你。但废话不多说，让我们进入本集节目。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到这个播客。很高兴你能回来收听又一期节目，和我们一起剖析20多岁时的心理。提前提醒一下，今天的节目自然会涵盖诸如性、性侵犯和其他成熟主题，同时也包括一些困难的主题。所以如果这些内容对你来说可能会觉得
hard to hear, please consider your own headspace and well-being. And whether or not now is the time to listen to this episode, it will still be here in a month, a year for you to come back to. So just remember to take care of yourselves. So guys, today's episode is hopefully going to be like the big sister slash best friend version of the sex education class you never had in school. We cover so many obviously, I think important topics on this podcast, like breakups and work and specific mental health issues, all things that, you know, have to do with our 20s. But sex is a part of our 20s. I don't often talk about and STIs, STDs are a part of that as well, not just a physical part of it, not just a risk part of it, but a psychological part of
很难接受，请照顾好你自己的心理状态和福祉。无论现在是不是收听这一集的最佳时机，它都会一直在那里，一个月后、一年后你都可以再回来听。所以只要记住照顾好自己。所以各位，今天的节目希望能成为你从未在学校上过的性教育课的“大姐姐”或“最好朋友”版本。我们在这个播客中涵盖了许多显而易见的、我认为很重要的主题，比如分手、工作和特定的心理健康问题，所有这些，你知道的，都与我们的20多岁有关。但性是我们20多岁的一部分。我并不常谈论性传播感染（STI）和性传播疾病（STD），它们也是其中的一部分，不仅仅是生理上的一部分，不仅仅是风险的一部分，对于我们许多人来说，它还是心理上的
our 20s for so many of us. SDIs are so common. They are also treatable or at the very least manageable when you have access to healthcare. But socially and emotionally speaking, they have such an impact still to this day on how we date, how we see ourselves, how we see others, how we see our future. Even if you are the most sex positive therapy literate person on the planet, I still think there is a huge taboo around sexually transmitted infections or diseases. And finding out you have one is always going to be shocking. It's always going to be or feel life altering or scary and it brings a lot of shame. And that's why I want to talk about how to approach this situation if it is the one that you found yourself in, from when you're diagnosed to bringing it up with a person you're seeing
20多岁的一部分。性传播感染非常普遍。它们也是可治疗的，或者至少在你能获得医疗服务时是可以控制的。但在社会和情感层面上，直到今天，它们对我们的约会方式、我们如何看待自己、如何看待他人、如何看待我们的未来，仍然产生着如此巨大的影响。即使你是这个星球上最具有性积极态度、最懂心理治疗的人，我仍然认为围绕性传播感染或疾病仍然存在巨大的禁忌。发现自己感染了某种疾病总是令人震惊的。它总是或让人觉得会改变一生、令人恐惧，并且会带来很多羞耻感。这就是为什么我想谈谈如果你发现自己处于这种情况下，该如何应对，从确诊到向你正在交往的人提起此事，再到应对它可能给你带来的羞耻感或情感打击。
to dealing with the shame or emotional toll that it may be taking on you. I just want to say it's going to be okay. You're going to be okay. SDIs have been a part of human history since human history began and the medical advances we have had recently as a society means that you're going to be taking good care of and, you know, you're probably. probably don't even realize how many people you talk to, walk by, admire or are friends with, have this experience as well. You know, how many people as well still get their love story and still have a relationship and have sex and get to know themselves and trust themselves and get their health back again.
我只想说，一切都会好起来的。你会没事的。自人类历史开始以来，性传播感染就一直是人类历史的一部分，而我们社会最近取得的医疗进步意味着你会得到很好的照顾，而且，你知道的，你可能甚至没有意识到有多少你交谈过、擦肩而过、欣赏过或作为朋友的人，也有过同样的经历。你知道，还有多少人同样收获了他们的爱情故事，依然拥有恋爱关系，享受性爱，了解自己并信任自己，最终恢复了健康。
So that's exactly what I want to focus on today. Quick note, this episode is more educational. It's not medical advice. So for personal guidance or if you feel like you might be experiencing any of these things we talk about on the show today, please go talk to a sexual health clinic or healthcare professional who can give you a bit more informed medical information. But without further ado, let's get into it. So before we dive further in, just a little clarity on the difference between SDIs and SDDs because I used to use these interchangeably. like I think a lot of people do, even medical professionals, and then one of my friends called me out on it,
所以这正是今天我想重点关注的内容。温馨提示，本集节目更具教育意义。它不构成医疗建议。因此，如果你需要个性化指导，或者觉得你可能正在经历节目中讨论的这些情况，请去咨询性健康诊所或医疗专业人员，他们可以为你提供更多知情的医疗信息。但废话不多说，我们开始吧。所以在我们深入探讨之前，先稍微厘清一下STI（性传播感染）和STD（性传播疾病）的区别，因为我过去也经常混用这两个词，
and I really appreciated her doing so, because STI's sexually transmitted infection, this is the broader term to describe infection caused by viruses, bacteria, or parasites that are passed through sexual contact. Someone might have an STI without having any symptoms at all, meaning it can be passed on without people knowing that they even have it. You usually catch them at the stage if you go for routine checks. STDs, sexually transmitted diseases, is when the initial infection has advanced to a point of significantly noticeable symptoms or disease. So basically if an SDI is left untreated, it can, but not always develop into an STD. A lot of professionals now actually advocate for the term SDI to be used more generally than the term disease because I think just diseases just feels like a stigmatizing term.
就像我认为很多人一样，甚至医疗专业人员也是如此，然后我的一个朋友指出了这一点，我很感激她这么做，因为STI——性传播感染（sexually transmitted infection），这是一个更广泛的术语，用来描述由病毒、寄生虫或通过性接触传播的细菌引起的感染。一个人可能患有STI但完全没有任何症状，这意味着它可能会在人们甚至不知道自己感染的情况下传播。如果你去做常规检查，通常会在这个阶段发现它们。STD——性传播疾病（sexually transmitted disease），是指最初的感染已经发展到出现明显显著症状或疾病的阶段。所以基本上，如果一个STI没有得到治疗，它可能会（但不总是）发展成一个STD。现在很多专业人员实际上倡导更广泛地使用“STI”这个词，而不是“疾病”（disease）这个词，因为我认为“疾病”听起来就像是一个带有污名化的词。
But I think that very simple language lesson, language shift is one that we can all integrate. Yeah, just for the better. I think if you grew up with the sex education that a lot of us had, SDIs you would think that they are the worst thing that could ever happen to you, number one, that your life would be over because of all those fear-based stories we were told. you might also have absorbed this idea that SDIs are really, really rare. Something that happens to, you know, that happen to reckless people or people who are careless. But oh my God, you would be so wrong.
但我认为这个非常简单的语言课程、语言转变是我们所有人都可以融入的。是的，为了更好的方向。我想如果你在成长过程中接受过我们很多人所经历的那种性教育，你会认为STI是你可能遇到的最糟糕的事情，第一，你的生活会完蛋，因为我们听过了所有那些基于恐惧的故事。你可能还吸收了这样一种观点，即STI非常非常罕见。那是发生在，你知道的，那些鲁莽的人或粗心大意的人身上的事情。但天哪，你大错特错了。
Globally, SDIs are way more common than you think. And this, I think, is the first step to feeling less isolated in this experience. Because if we don't talk about this openly, you truly think, like, like you were the only one to have ever had this experience. But get this, the World Health Organization estimates, I think that it's more than like a million curable STIs acquired every single day. Day, daily. And in 2020, it was estimated, I think, 374 million new infections
在全球范围内，STI比你想象的要普遍得多。我认为，这是在这个经历中感到不再那么孤立的第一步。因为如果我们不公开谈论这件事，你真的会觉得，就像，你是唯一一个有过这种经历的人。但你知道吗，世界卫生组织估计，每天有超过一百万例可治愈的性传播感染病例发生。每天，天天如此。据估计，在2020年，
of the four most curable STIs, so chlamydia gonorrhea, syphilis, and I can't remember the third one, were diagnosed during the, that year. Here's another very important scientific fact that I want to bring up as early as I possibly can in this episode, chlamydia, gonorrhea, syphilis, HIV, HPV, herpes. Every single SDI has either a preventative intervention, a cure or a highly effective treatment that manages symptoms, every single one. And with early detection, the chances of seeing no symptoms, no changes, or very minimal symptoms or getting to a full recovery is so much higher. Here are some positive things to know about recent treatment developments. If you're, you know, scared in the wake of
四种最常见的可治愈性传播感染（即衣原体感染、淋病、梅毒，还有第三种我记不清了）的新发感染病例达到了3.74亿起，是在那一年被诊断出来的。这里还有一个非常重要的科学事实，我想尽我所能在这集节目的早期提出来：衣原体感染、淋病、梅毒、艾滋病毒（HIV）、人乳头瘤病毒（HPV）、疱疹。每一种性传播感染要么有预防性干预措施、治愈方法，要么有能控制症状的高效疗法，每一种都是如此。而且通过早期发现，看不到症状、没有变化、症状极其轻微或完全康复的机会要高得多。以下是关于近期治疗进展的一些积极消息。如果你，你知道的，在自己确诊后感到害怕，或者害怕去了解结果或去接受检测。首先，衣原体感染、淋病、梅毒——你在20多岁时最常感染的一些性传播感染——都可以通过抗生素治愈。这算是个好消息。更多好消息是，2025年，墨尔本的研究人员在开发艾滋病毒治愈方法的道路上又迈进了一步。我认为那是我们最恐惧的性传播疾病。不过现在，服用艾滋病毒药物的人的预期寿命与没有感染艾滋病毒的人相同。他们中的一些人可能永远不会出现任何症状。让我们继续关注好消息。还是2025年，澳大利亚宣布其有望消除宫颈癌，宫颈癌基本上完全是由HPV引起的。同样在去年，一种能将病毒载量降低94%的新型疱疹疗法进入了二期临床试验。英国正在紧锣密鼓地推广第一支淋病疫苗。我强调这一切的原因是，当你接到医生或性健康诊所的电话，或者收到伴侣发来的短信说“嘿，你感染了或者你处于危险之中”时，那种感觉就像脚下的地板突然塌陷，感觉这就是末日。这在生理上也可能是痛苦的。它会在许多方面扰乱我们的生活。有时所有这些情绪会压垮我们，并促使我们选择逃避。
your own diagnosis or you're scared to find out or to go get tested. For starters, Chlamydia gonorrhea syphilis, some of the most common SDIs that you get in your 20s, are all curable with antibiotics. That is some good news. Some more good news in 2025, researchers in Melbourne got one step closer to developing a cure for HIV. I think that is the SDD we are most fearful of. Right now, though, people on medication for HIV have the same life expectancy as people without HIV. Some of them may never experience any symptoms. Let's keep going with the good news. 2025 again, Australia announced it was on track to eliminate cervical cancer, which is basically completely caused due to HBV. Last year as well, a new treatment for herpes that dropped the viral
你自己的诊断，或者你害怕去了解或去检测。首先，衣原体、淋病、梅毒，这些你在20岁时最容易感染的性传播感染，都是可以通过抗生素治愈的。这是一个好消息。另一个好消息是，在2025年，墨尔本的研究人员在开发艾滋病治愈方法的道路上又迈进了一步。我认为那是我们最恐惧的性传播疾病。不过现在，服用艾滋病药物的人的预期寿命与没有感染艾滋病的人是一样的。他们中的一些人可能永远不会出现任何症状。我们继续看好消息。还是在2025年，澳大利亚宣布有望消除宫颈炎，这种病基本上完全是由HBV引起的。同样在去年，一种降低病毒载量的新型疱疹治疗方法问世
load by 94% moved to phase two trials. The first ever gonorrhea vaccine is being rolled out in the UK as we speak. Like, the reason I emphasize all this is because when you get that call from your doctor or the sexual health clinic or get a text from a partner that's like, hey, you have this or you're at risk, it can feel like the floor has dropped out from beneath you and that this is the end. It can be physically painful as well. It can be disruptive in many ways to our lives. Sometimes all that emotion can overwhelm us and can prompt avoidance.
比起直面现实，逃避现实似乎更容易。我可不想让这意味着你因为假设根本没有治疗方法，就不去立即寻求治疗或获得你需要的帮助。你假设你的生活现在已经结束了。你相信了许多我认为我们在小时候被灌输的、非常可怕且极具危害性的说法。我知道我一直在谈论这个。
It's easier to look away from the situation. than to face it head on. And I don't want that to mean that you don't pursue treatment immediately or get the help you need because you assume there isn't any. You assume that your life is now over. You believe a lot of the narratives that I think we were told when we were kids that were very scary and very harmful. I know I speak about this all the time.
我讨厌人们试图把所有事情都往积极的方向美化，试图让你觉得你几乎必须对你的处境和正在经历的事情保持乐观。但在围绕性传播感染存在如此多的制造恐惧和羞耻感的情况下，我觉得有必要用一些真相来平衡这一点。你会没事的。我们在社会上没有更多地强调这一点，就像我们总是积极谈论的那样。
I hate when people try and put a positive spin on everything and try to make you think you have to be almost like optimistic about you know, about your circumstances and what you're going through. But with how much fear mongering and shame surrounds STIs, I feel like it's necessary to just balance that with some truth. You are going to be okay. The fact that we're not emphasizing this more in society, the way, you know, we always talk so positively.
你总能在新闻里看到癌症临床试验成功或痴呆症临床试验成功。我们从来不会对性传播感染做同样的事情。我认为这也证明了我们对性传播感染的集体态度是多么带有偏见，医疗方面的胜利从未得到关注，同时也证明了人们仍然认为恐惧和羞耻感可以通过恐吓人们不要发生性行为来让性传播感染奇迹般地消失，因为我们只强调最糟糕的情况。到现在还相信这一点的人，简直就是白痴。
You always see in the news when cancer trials have been successful or dementia trials have been successful. We never do the same for like STIs. And I think that also proves how prejudiced our collective attitudes towards SDIs are, that medical wins never get the attention, but also how much people still think that fear and shame is going to somehow make SDIs go away by scaring people into not having sex because we just emphasize the worst case scenario. People who still believe that, like, at this stage, are so, like, they're idiots.
这根本无法阻止，羞耻感无法阻止人们。这几乎就像是一种奇怪的反向心理学思维，觉得如果我们谈论这是多么普遍且可治疗，人们就会变得粗心大意，因为有一种假设认为，只有粗心大意才会让人感染性传播感染——这不是真的。但这意味着，当我们感染时，我们会惊恐万状，并认为我们的生活已经结束了；我们不去接受检测，因为我们害怕知道结果；你没有得到你需要的帮助，因为你认为每个人都会评判你，然后问题变得更严重，症状变得更严重，也许感染、病毒、细菌被传播了出去，没有人能过得更好。
Like, it doesn't stop, shame doesn't stop people. It's almost like this weird reverse psychology. thinking of like if we talk about how common and treatable this is then people will be careless because there's this assumption that only carelessness is what makes someone get an STI that is not true but what that means is that when we do we're terrified and we think our life is over we don't get tested because we're scared to know the outcome and you don't get the help you need because you think everybody's going to judge you and then the problem gets worse symptoms get worse perhaps the the infection, the virus, the bacteria gets passed on, nobody is better off.
感染性传播感染在生理上是一个打击，它是一个需要治疗和医疗护理的健康问题，但在情感上，我认为由于污名化，它带来的打击也相当大，这正是我们在这里要讨论的。一些心理学研究甚至将感染性传播感染贴上了创伤性事件的标签。它可能会引发类似于经历悲伤的情绪反应，你知道的，否认、对传染给你的人感到愤怒、对世界感到愤怒、讨价还价，还有社交退缩和孤立。你知道，我曾有一个朋友，被一个她交往了大概六个月的男生传染了性传播感染。
Getting an STI is a shock physically and it is a health concern that needs treatment and medical care, but emotionally I think the toll is also quite high because of the stigma and that's really what we're talking about here. Some psychological researchers even labeled getting an STI as a traumatic event. It may trigger a similar emotional reaction to the experience of grief, you know, denial, anger at the person who gave it to you, anger at the world, bargaining, but also social withdrawal and isolation. You know, I had a friend of mine get an SDI from a guy. She'd been seeing for like six months.
这是她第一个发生性关系的男生，他是出轨了还是之前就感染了，我们可能永远不得而知，但我记得她因为恐惧和害怕别人的评判，将近一年都没有告诉我们。我记得她当时说，我只是觉得这说明了我作为一个人的问题——这简直是对我的人格和心理的直接宣判。社会学解释了那种感觉是什么，它被称为“被玷污的身份效应”（spoiled identity effect）。当人们开始认为自己被某种理应说明他们的人格或本性的疾病所定义时，就会产生这种效应。在某个阶段，有人将这个阴险的想法植入我们的脑海：性传播感染是那些粗心大意的人、
It was the first person she'd ever slept with, whether he'd cheated on her or had it before, we may never know, but I remember she didn't tell us for like almost a year because of fear and the fear of judgment. and I think I remember her being like I just felt like it said something about me as a person like it's a literal verdict on my character and psychology sociology explains what that feeling is it's called the spoiled identity effect it's when people start to see themselves defined by a condition that supposedly says something about their character or who they are at some stage someone put this insidious idea on our head that SDIs are what happened to careless people,
不道德的人、不自律的人、不纯洁的人才会得的病。所以我也一定是所有这些东西。这种评判是一种人类的评判。这是一种人造的道德评判。归根结底，这取决于我们如何对待性，以及我们大多数人都在这样一种文化中长大：性本身就已经是一个高度禁忌的话题，是一个你被要求保持低调、不能承认自己想要、
immoral people, undisciplined people, impure people. And so I must be all those things. That judgment is a human judgment. It's a moral judgment that is man-made. And it really comes down to how we treat sex and how most of us are raised in a culture where sex is already very taboo, something you're meant to be very discreet about, not admit that you want to. and definitely not make so-called mistakes around. So when you throw into it an infection caught through sex, suddenly it's like, what did you expect? Like, this was a choice you had. We can hold you accountable.
绝对不能围绕它犯下所谓“错误”的话题。所以，当你在其中加入通过性行为感染的疾病时，突然间，这就好像是：你还期望什么？这本就是你的选择。我们可以追究你的责任。这太荒谬了。有一项非常引人注目的社会心理学研究表明，这种道德污染的叙事在阻止人们寻求帮助以及实际上让性传播感染恶化方面有多么强大。在发表在《人格与社会心理学公报》（Personality and Social Psychology Bulletin）上的五项独立实验中，研究人员发现，仅仅将“无保护性行为”加入到疾病传播可能途径的列表中，就会让人对感染者产生更多评判，并让参与者相信，如果他们得了这种疾病，其他人也会认为他们更不道德。因此，此列表中的感染疾病或状况实际上保持不变。其中一些疾病如神经退行性病变、癌症、
And that's ludicrous. There's a really striking piece of social psychology research that shows how powerful that moral contamination narrative is in stopping people from getting help and actually making SDI's worse. Across five separate experiments published in the personality and social psychology bulletin, researchers found that simply adding unprotected sex to a list of possible ways a disease could be transmitted, made people judge an infected person more, and made participants believe that if they got the disease, others would see them as less moral too. So the infections of diseases that conditions on this list stayed the same. Some of them were like neurological decline, cancer,
脱发。但一旦性行为以某种方式与这些疾病联系起来，这些研究表明，人们对它们的看法会立刻发生变化，尽管除了这个标签之外什么都没有变。这对我来说太搞笑了，如果我们去餐馆吃饭，食物导致我们食物中毒，你不会把这一切归咎于自己，然后觉得：“哦天哪，我太不道德了，太令人作呕了，因为我选择去那里吃饭。”其他人也不会对你有这种看法。你只是一个满足了进食这种人类需求的人。而你在吃的东西上运气不好罢了。
hair loss. But once sex was associated in any way with these diseases, these studies showed that people just saw them differently immediately, even though nothing had changed except for that label. It's so funny to me because if we eat out at a restaurant and the food gives us food poisoning, you would not turn that on yourself and be like, oh my goodness, I'm so immoral and disgusting because I chose to eat there. And other people wouldn't think that of you either. You're just someone who fulfilled a human need to eat. And you got unlucky with what you ate.
所以，如果我们满足了另一种人类需求，发生了性行为，但运气不好感染了性传播感染，为什么这会有所不同？这是一个引导性问题。我们都知道为什么。因为，再次说明，社会几代人以来一直试图通过羞耻感作为其首要工具来控制性。为了进一步理解这种污名化，让我们简短地回顾一下历史。我认为，如果性没有被妖魔化，性传播感染也不会被如此污名化，
So if we engage in another human need and we have sex and we get unlucky and we catch an SDI, why is that different? It's a leading question. We all know why. Because of the way, again, society has tried to control sex for generations upon generations using shame as their number one tool to do so. To understand the stigma further, let's get a little bit historical for a second. SDIs, I don't think, would be so stigmatized if sex wasn't so stigmatized
因为这曾被用来控制男人和女人，但主要是女性。这曾被用来控制女性，让她们的行为方式符合他人的需求。性传播感染之所以被视为（我讨厌用这个词）肮脏的东西，很大一部分原因是因为性，尤其是随意性行为（casual sex），被视为不纯洁的。这与宗教喜欢使用的许多纯洁性语言形成鲜明对比，宗教既将其作为一种精神范畴——心灵纯洁、心地纯洁——也将其作为一种社会控制机制。将女性的身体塑造成可以是有道德的、干净的、可控的，或者相反地，可以是罪恶的、被玷污的和危险的。
because it wasn't used to control men and women, but mainly women. And it wasn't used to control women to get them to behave in a way that suited the needs of others. A huge part of why STIs are seen as, and I hate using this word, but as dirty, is because sex, particularly casual sex, is seen as impure. And that contrast to a lot of the purity language that religion likes to use both as a spiritual category, that you're pure of mind, pure of heart, and also as a social mechanism of control. Framing women's bodies is something that can be virtuous, can be clean, can be controlled, or conversely can be sinful and tainted and dangerous.
有太多方式让宗教将纯洁的女性神圣化、将童贞神圣化，甚至达到生物学上不可能的地步，比如圣母玛利亚既是处女却又怀孕了。相比之下，这也让性行为感到羞耻，让不纯洁感到羞耻，并将其作为另一种评判某人道德的方式。从历史上看，我们不得不问这个问题：为什么女性因发生性行为而必须感到羞耻？为什么她们因发生随意性行为而必须感到羞耻？因为在许多方面，我认为她们被当作财产对待。她们注定只能依附于一个男人，以便让他知道她所生的孩子是他的，这样他的财富、他的继承权就会留给某种属于他的血亲，而不是别的男人的血亲，一个能给他这种安全感的女人，
there are so many ways that religion idolizes the pure woman, idolizes virginity, literally to the point of biological impossibility, like Virgin Mary being a virgin but being pregnant. And in contrast, this also shames sex and it shames impurity, uses it as another way to judge the morality of someone. Historically, we have to ask this question, why would women need to be shamed for having sex? Why would they have to be shamed for having casual sex? because in many ways I think they were treated like property. They were meant to be solely bound to one man so that he could know the children she bore were his so that his wealth, his inheritance would go to something, his kin that belonged to him, not some other man, and a woman that could give him that almost like security
因为她在遇到他时是个处女，因为她在和他在一起时保持受控，她就是一笔资产。如果我们想要，如果他们想要更多女性那样行事，最简单的方法就是找到方法去羞辱那些不这样做的人，并基本上通过社会学习和我们目击那些行为不端者的经历而产生的替代性学习来改变行为。任何与性有关的、不以所谓传统方式进行的事情因此都变得可耻，尤其是性传播感染。
because she was a virgin when she met him, because she stayed controlled when she was with him, she was an asset. If we want, and if they wanted more women to act like that, the easiest way to make them do so is to find ways to humiliate those who wouldn't and to basically change behaviour through social learning and vicarious learning of us witnessing the experiences of people who acted out of line. Anything to do with sex that's not done in quote unquote traditional, the traditional way, therefore becomes shameful, but especially SDIs.
不仅对女性如此，对任何行为不符合传统规范的人来说也是如此，不仅仅是对女性，对任何行为偏离人们对性行为应有规范的人来说也是如此。酷儿性行为是另一个我们能看到这种现象的领域。你知道，我们无法抛开对性传播感染的羞耻感来不谈艾滋病流行，也无法不谈早期HIV和艾滋病是如何没有被当作一场医疗危机来对待的。它被塑造成了一场道德危机。当时充斥着诸如“无辜的受害者”与“有罪的受害者”之类的言论，整个群体，
And not just for women, but for anyone who is like acting out of the traditional way, not just for women, but for anyone who is like acting out of line with how people should be having sex. Queer sex is another area where we see that. You know, we can't talk about the shame around STIs and not talk about the AIDS epidemic and how HIV and AIDS wasn't treated as the medical crisis that it was in the early days. It was framed as a moral crisis. There was all this language of like innocent victims versus guilty victims and entire groups,
尤其是男同性恋者，受到指责、被剥夺人性。任由其痛苦，仿佛疾病是越轨性行为应得的后果，这再次归咎于宗教以及它如何决定对与错、好与坏。通过这种方式，我们来到了今天。性传播感染就像是一个道德晴雨表，表明你越界了，或者你做出了一个糟糕的选择，违背了人们认为你应该如何行为的方式。如果你仔细想想，无保护性行为带来的唯一其他生物学影响就是计划外怀孕，这同样带有其自身的道德内涵。但同样，主要影响的是
especially gay men, were blamed dehumanized. left to suffer as if illness was a deserved consequence of deviant sex, again, because of religion and how it determined right and wrong and good and bad. In this way, this is where we are now. SDI's act as kind of a moral barometer that you've crossed a line or you've made a bad choice contrary to how people think you should behave. If you think about it, like the only other kind of biological impact to unprotected sex is like unplanned pregnancy, which also has its own moral connotations. But again, predominantly affects
女性。现在，我能听到人们的大脑在飞速运转，心想：“你知道的，你也可以争辩说，在过去，羞耻感是人们对抗性传播感染的唯一公共安全机制。”比如过去的性传播感染是致命的。它们非常严重。它们会要了你的命。他们可能拥有的唯一选择是预防性的，是利用情感杠杆来提倡禁欲或一夫一妻制以阻止传播。这种观点有其道理，但如今情况已不再如此，正如我们所讨论的，现在有了更多的医疗护理。羞耻感之所以主要挥之不去，是因为历史、宗教以及对好与坏、对与错、纯洁与肮脏的看法等因素所投下的道德阴影。
women. Now, I can hear like people's brains ticking and being like, you know, you could make the argument that back in the day as well, shame was the only public safety mechanism people had against SDIs. Like SDIs back then were deadly. They were very serious. They would kill you. The only option they maybe had was preventative and was to, you know, use emotional, levers to promote abstinence or monogamy to stop the spread. There is an argument for that, but nowadays that's not the case anymore, as we've spoken about, there's a lot more medical care. The shame primarily lingers because of this moral shadow that's cast by history and religion and perceptions of good and bad, right and wrong, pure and dirty it amongst other things.
而且，我之所以纠缠于这段历史，是因为在心理学上这很重要。正是这些因素塑造了态度和文化记忆，这意味着你背负着羞耻感，这意味着存在这样一种思维捷径：性传播感染等于不负责任，性等于风险，诊断等于羞辱等于生命结束。如果你感染了性传播感染，并且正在应对内化或外部的污名化，我认为接受治疗显然是第一步。第二步是知道你并不孤单，但第三步是能够去审视，为什么偏偏有人想让你感觉糟糕，为什么他们想让你自我规训并内化你的羞耻感，为什么他们想让你对它闭口不谈。性并不是坏事，随意性行为也不是
And the reason, the reason I'm lingering on the history of this is because psychologically it's important. This is what creates attitudes and cultural memory that mean that you are carrying shame and that mean that there is this mental shortcut that SDI equals irresponsible, sex equals risky, diagnosis equals humiliation equals life over. If you have an SDI and you're managing internalized or even outside stigma, I think getting treatment is obviously step number one. step number two is knowing you're not alone but step number three is being able to interrogate why exactly people want you to feel bad why they want you to self-police and internalize your shame why they want you to not talk about it sex isn't bad casual sex isn't
坏事。感染性传播感染并不代表你肮脏或成了残次品——我讨厌这个词——实际上就像任何人都有可能感染一样，任何人仅仅通过出生、通过静脉吸毒、输血到非自愿性行为都可能感染。你猜怎么着？即使你感染的原因是因为，好吧，你确实没用安全套，或者你对对方不够了解。这依然不意味着你罪有应得或不道德，或者别人试图灌输给你的任何想法。这里没有无辜和不无辜的人之分，因为没有人做错任何事。让我们来谈谈第四件你可能觉得现在压得你喘不过气来的事，那就是你对未来的信仰。对于20多岁感染了性传播感染的人来说，一个很大的担忧，尤其是那些可能不会立刻或永远消失的感染，
bad getting an sDI doesn't make you dirty or damaged goods i hate that word quite literally like anyone could get one anyone simply from being born with it from drug needle use, blood transfusions to unconsensual sex. And guess what? Even if you got it because, yeah, you just didn't use a condom or you didn't know the person that well. It still doesn't make you deserving or immoral or whatever others want to convince you. There are no innocent and non-innocent people in this because no one's done anything wrong. Let's talk about the fourth thing that you may feel is weighing pretty heavy on you right now, which is your beliefs about the future. A big concern for people who get an SDI in their 20s, especially one that maybe doesn't go away immediately or ever,
是关于人际关系，以及性传播感染将如何影响他们结识新欢、建立羁绊的方式，以及他们是否会被接纳。2%。这是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中。我剖析了在我们这个奇异的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。
is about relationships and how an SDI will impact how they'll meet people, bond with people, whether they'll be accepted. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange, modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即T-W-O-Persent，可在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。每个男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，千万别惹乡下女孩。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl.
玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也千万别惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在新一季的《闺蜜们》中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都与同一个高产的诈骗犯约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？
You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of The Girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me?
警察似乎并不在意，所以她们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼去吧。我发誓我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应得的下场。收听《闺蜜们。相信我，宝贝》。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？
The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the Girlfriends. Trust me, babe. on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾往事》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill,
滔滔不绝地谈论80年代的快克可卡因。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不仅因为快克。我随时准备一整天都在谈论快克，只是想让大家知道。我的意思是，此时此刻，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始发现这里有一条贯穿线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在了台面上。谢谢你补充完这句话。是的。
waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes.
我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾往事》。欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难一课》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field
以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入到追逐中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，但我们仍在追逐，并且我们不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们在盯着记分牌。生活变成了一场关于胜利与失败的游戏。
and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得作为一个好人很重要，当你活在世上时，还是你之所以是个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正成为一个好人。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《艰难一课》中，我们进行关于治愈、成长、父爱、压力和使命的真实对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序，搜索《艰难一课》，立即收听。污名化常常让我们对与潜在伴侣谈论性传播感染的走向持有更加消极的看法。我们经常预料到，我认为，会有更严厉的评判、厌恶以及可能的拒绝。尽管在医学上、社会上、人际关系上，许多人
Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app, search Learn the Hardway, and listen now. Stigma often gives us a much more negative view on how conversations about SDIs with potential partners are going to go. We often anticipate, I think, harsher judgment, disgust and maybe rejection. Even though medically, socially, relationally, like a lot of people
带着这些诊断建立了非常健康、充满爱意的生活。因为正如我们所看到的，你仍然可以采取步骤来尽量减少或消除风险。痛苦的部分在于，当你经历那一次负面的经历，或者那一次你确实遭遇了污名化的时刻。此外，痛苦的部分还在于回想那个时刻及其潜在的可能性。这真的开始塑造你的行为方式，你可能会回避约会、回避亲密关系，停留在并不对劲的恋爱关系中，因为你觉得自己不配拥有更多，或者你有点怀疑是否会有人想要你。你知道的，我有一个朋友，她几年前感染了疱疹，是的，几年前，她说——我记得她当时有这样一刻的心情：“这就是我现在的相亲池吗？是不是会变小？是不是只能跟有疱疹的人约会？难道那些才是我唯一能约会的人？这些是我的选择吗？”你知道的，Hinge（约会软件）上并没有那种过滤器，上面写着“有疱疹的人，是或否”或者是一个过滤器来弄清楚这一点，或者一个提示来做到这一点。这太难了。而最简单的事情依然是完全避免约会，因为回避可以暂时减少焦虑，所以它会成为默认的应对策略，尽管这违背了你对未来的期望。我知道，我知道要相信你会找到一个能理解这一点且不会妄加评判的人真的很困难，但有太多这样的真实故事发生了。我强烈建议——我知道这听起来很奇怪——去Reddit页面和支持页面，搜索诸如
build very healthy, loving lives with these diagnoses. Because as we've seen, there are still steps you can take to minimize or eradicate risk. The painful part is when you have that one negative experience or that one moment where you do come up against stigma. Also, the painful part is thinking about that moment and the potential of it. And that can really start to shape how you act and you might avoid dating, avoid intimacy, stay in relationships that aren't right because you feel disqualified from wanting more or you kind of you wonder if anybody's going to want you you know i had a friend of mine she got herpes a couple years ago now yeah a couple of years ago and she was like i remember her having this moment of being like is this the dating pool for me now is it just going
带着这些诊断建立非常健康、充满爱的生活。因为正如我们所看到的，你仍然可以采取步骤来尽量减少或消除风险。痛苦的部分在于，当你经历那一次不愉快的经历，或者遇到那一次面临污名化的时刻。同时，痛苦的部分还在于回想那个时刻及其潜在影响。这真的会开始影响你的行为方式，你可能会逃避约会、逃避亲密关系，或者留在并不合适的感情中，因为你觉得自己不配拥有更多，或者你会想是否有人还会想要你。你知道的，我有一个朋友，她几年前得了疱疹，对，就是几年前，她当时就有过这样一种时刻，心想这难道就是我以后的约会池了吗，难道只能
to be smaller is it just going to be people with herpes is that the only people i can date are those my options and you know there's not exactly a filter on hinge that's like people with herpes yes or no or like a filter to like figure it out or a prompt that makes that's hard that's hard and the easiest thing is again to avoid dating altogether because avoidance temporarily reduces anxiety so it can become the default coping strategy even though it goes against your hopes for the future and I know I know it can be really difficult to believe that you'll find someone who will understand this and who won't pass judgment, but there are so many accounts of this happening. I would highly recommend, and I know this is going to be weird, but going to Reddit pages and support pages and looking up
“带疱疹约会”、“带HIV约会”、“带乙肝约会”这样的内容，因为这些故事是如此坦诚、美好，而且相当客观。就像它们是客观的，这正是我喜欢的。基本上，它们的意思是：恋爱很难。约会很难。这很难。但无论环境如何，总有成功的故事。你甚至不需要找得那么远。你会发现那些真正非常浪漫的故事，主角的处境可能和你现在差不多。让我们来谈谈你什么时候应该告诉别人你感染了性传播感染，因为我觉得这有点争议。这就像是一个待辩论的话题。人们对此有不同的看法。我从STI项目以及网站them.com上的一篇精彩文章中获取了很多相关信息，同时也从经历过这种情况并以几种方式处理过它的朋友那里了解到了经验。显然，唯一的限制是你需要在发生性行为之前或在可能发生传染之前告诉某人。然后由你决定你想在什么时候说。我有一个朋友在第一次约会时就告诉对方。我有另一个朋友在第四次或第五次约会时告诉对方，比如当你知道，事情将要朝着性方向快速发展的时候。另一个限制是，最好不要在即将发生性行为前的那几分钟或那一刻告诉对方，主要是因为说实话，如果他们生气或沮丧，你就会处于脆弱的境地，而且有时没有人能保持清醒的头脑，你们两个都希望
like dating with herpes, dating with HIV, dating with hepby, because the stories are so honest and beautiful and just kind of matter of fact. Like they're matter of fact, which is what I like. Basically, they're like relationships are hard. Dating is hard. This is hard. But there are always success stories regardless of circumstances. You don't even have to look that far. You will find genuinely very romantic stories of people who are probably in a similar situation to what you are in now. Let's talk about when you should tell someone you have an SDI because I feel like this is kind of controversial. It's like up for debate. People have different opinions about it. I got a lot of info on this from the SDI project and also from this amazing article from the website.
比如带疱疹约会、带艾滋病约会、带乙肝约会，因为这些故事非常真实、美好，而且相当客观。就像它们是客观事实一样，这也是我所喜欢的。基本上，它们就像是在说，维系感情很难。约会很难。这一切都很难。但无论环境如何，总会有成功的故事。你甚至不需要看太远。你会发现许多真正非常浪漫的故事，主角们所处的情况可能和你现在的情况类似。我们来谈谈你应该什么时候告诉别人你得了性传播感染，因为我觉得这有点争议。这还有待讨论。对此人们有不同的看法。我从SDI项目以及网站上一篇精彩的文章中获取了大量这方面的信息。
them.com, but also from friends who have been in this situation and how they've dealt with it in a couple of ways. Obviously, the only constraint is that you want to tell somebody before you have sex or before like transmission is possible. It's then your call from there when you want to do it. I have a friend who tells someone on the first date. I have another friend who tells them on the fourth or fifth date, like when, you know, things are kind of going to like sexually speed up. The other constraint is that it's probably wise to not tell them in the minutes or moments before you're about to have sex, mainly because let's be honest, you're in a vulnerable position if they get angry or frustrated, but also sometimes nobody is thinking clearly and you want to both
them.com，还有从曾经历过这种情况的朋友那里了解到的经验，以及他们是如何以几种方式处理这一问题的。很显然，唯一的限制是你需要在发生性行为之前，或者在可能发生病毒传播之前告诉对方。之后何时告诉对方，完全由你决定。我有一个朋友在第一次约会时就会告诉对方。我还有另一个朋友在第四次或第五次约会时才告诉对方，比如你知道，当事情快要发展到发生性关系的时候。另一个限制是，最好不要在准备发生性关系前的几分钟或那一刻才告诉对方，主要是因为说实话，如果对方生气或沮丧，你就会处于一个脆弱的境地，而且有时大家脑子都不太清醒，你需要双方都
have a clear risk assessment. Over text or over a call is often really wise or a nice way to do it, or in a nice, quiet, public spot where you feel safe and feel like emotions are going to be manageable, I think on the whole, a good structure for this would go something like, number one, like signal to them you want to talk about health and sexual health, make that clear, put it in the subject line, share the diagnosis with their matter of factly, share what you do to manage the risk and how much of a risk there is, and kind of invite any questions and, like, give them time. I think brushing up on your own knowledge and research and education,
进行清晰的风险评估。通过发短信或打电话通常是非常明智或很好的做法，或者在一个你感到安全、情绪易于控制的安静公共场所。总体而言，一个好的交流结构大概是这样的：第一，向对方表明你想谈论健康和性健康，把这一点明确表达出来，写在主题行里；客观地分享诊断结果；分享你为控制风险所采取的措施以及风险究竟有多大；最后邀请对方提出任何问题，并给予他们时间。我认为，温习相关的知识、研究和教育，
is also great. They'll probably have a lot of questions and you will be a great person to answer them. Give them stats, you know, almost two-thirds of the population. Either has the herpes simplex virus one or two. Treatment has lowered my viral load. I'm not having an outbreak. My doctor has given me this specific advice or that specific advice. I know that there are the preventative rates of vaccines, whatever it is. A lot of the time, your ability to share this with the other person is going to be appreciated because that's trust, that's honesty, that's maturity. That's a beautiful way to handle a situation. And I think even at times it deepens the connection to have this thing that you've shared with them. Also, this was advice from my friend actually. She was like, you can tell
也是非常棒的做法。他们可能会有很多问题，而你将是回答这些问题的绝佳人选。提供一些统计数据，你知道的，差不多三分之二的人口要么感染了单纯疱疹病毒一型，要么感染了二型。治疗已经降低了我的病毒载量。我没有发作。我的医生给了我这方面的具体建议或那方面的具体建议。我知道疫苗有预防比率，诸如此类。很多时候，你能够与对方分享这一点会受到赞赏，因为这是信任，是诚实，是成熟。这是处理这种情况的一种美妙方式。而且我认为，有时这甚至会深化你们之间的联系，因为你与他们分享了这样一件事情。另外，这是我朋友给我的建议。她说，你可以
a lot about someone from their reaction. You can tell a lot about their character, about how they'll handle surprising news, how open they are to learning from their reaction. Listen, there is that chance that you might share it with somebody and they might reject you. Rejection of any kindness upsetting. But when it's something as sensitive as this, it's going to feel really personal. And I'm really sorry. I'm sorry, especially if you saw it going somewhere or you like really clicked with them. I know especially it can be hard to believe the age old like, well, they just weren't right for you because, you know,
从一个人的反应中看出很多东西。你可以看出他们的品格，看出他们将如何处理令人惊讶的消息，看出他们对学习的开放程度。听清楚了，你确实有可能将这件事告诉某人，而遭到他们的拒绝。任何形式的拒绝都让人心烦。但当涉及到如此敏感的事情时，感觉就会非常私人化。我真的很遗憾。我很遗憾，特别是如果你曾觉得这段感情会有所发展，或者你真的很喜欢对方。我知道，要相信“他们只是不适合你”这句老话尤其困难，因为，你知道的，
it's not something about your personality, it's not something about the situation, it's just unfortunate biology, and that can feel really brutal that if things were different, it could be different. If you feel that real sting of shame or embarrassment, you didn't do anything wrong. You haven't done anything wrong. In fact, it's the complete opposite. You disclose so that the other person could make an informed decision. You exhibited honesty and kindness, and a lot of people don't do that. Maybe the reason you got an STI is because somebody else didn't do that. Even if the outcome hurts, you did the emotionally mature, ethically solid thing and you will always have that knowledge about your own character. The thing is, they are allowed to have a boundary
这并不是你性格的问题，也不是情境的问题，这只是不幸的生物学现象。如果事情有所不同，结果可能会不同，这种感觉会非常残忍。如果你感到了真正的羞耻或尴尬，你并没有做错任何事。你没有做错任何事。事实上，情况恰恰相反。你进行坦白是为了让对方能够做出明智的决定。你表现出了诚实和善良，而很多人并没有做到这一点。也许你感染性传播感染（STI）的原因正是因为别人没有这样做。即使结果令人痛苦，你也做了情感上成熟、伦理上正确的事情，你将永远拥有对自己品格的这种认知。问题是，他们有权为
about risk. People's risk tolerance varies. Some people might be more cautious. Some people might have health anxiety. They might be immunocompromise. Some people have past trauma. Some people just aren't ready for a situation that requires extra care from them, extra communication, extra, extra thought. Their decision is simply a preference and a boundary they have. It's not a verdict. It's not a verdict on you as a person. Even if it does hurt a little, I think a good response is a simple grounded one, something like, thanks for being honest, I understand you have to do what feels right for you.
风险设定界限。人们的风险承受能力各不相同。有些人可能更谨慎。有些人可能有健康焦虑。他们可能是免疫力低下者。有些人有过去的创伤。有些人只是还没准备好面对需要自己付出额外关怀、额外沟通和额外思考的情况。他们的决定只是一种偏好和他们设定的界限。这并不是对你的评判。这并不是对你这个人本身的评判。即使确实有点受伤，我认为好的回应是一个简单、脚踏实地的回应，比如：谢谢你的坦诚，我理解你必须做对自己感觉正确的事。
That's enough. a lot of people's immediate reactions as well comes from outdated narratives on sexual health rather than medical understanding. Even very smart, kind people can have massive gaps in sexual health knowledge because sex is taught pretty poorly, still not talked about.
这就够了。许多人本能的直接反应也源于对性健康的过时观念，而不是医学理解。即使是非常聪明、善良的人，在性健康知识方面也可能会有巨大的盲区，因为性教育一直以来都教得很差，而且仍然很少被谈论。
Literally, I got my sex ed from like my 45-year-old gym teacher and he couldn't tell me how lesbians had sex. Like, he couldn't tell us anything. So that is the knowledge that a lot of us are coming into this. with. People often react to the idea, not the actual risk. You know, they're humans. We operate on very easy mental shortcuts and this is like a prime example of one of them. That being said, as well, if they do react with extreme judgment, pointed insults, character insults, they've
真的，我的性教育是从我45岁的体育老师那里学来的，他甚至讲不清楚女同性恋是如何发生性行为的。他什么也讲不出来。所以这就是我们许多人带着的知识背景。人们往往是对这种概念做出反应，而不是对实际风险。你知道的，他们是人类。我们靠非常简单的思维捷话运转，这就是其中的一个典型例子。话虽如此，如果他们确实做出了极度评判、尖锐侮辱或人身攻击的反应，他们就已经
gone past the point of just showing respect in a boundary. They're using stigma to position themselves as superior, that's not a person who is safe for vulnerability. If it's via text and they're getting very harsh, you don't own them a debate. You can simply stop responding. It might sound controversial. It's not your job to educate everybody. Your mental health is worth more than proving you're not gross or tainted or whatever they're saying. I hate those words, but like it's, you don't, you don't have to be the one who changes their mind. Send them some resources. Send them the stats and then leave the situation. Okay, as we wrap up, let's quickly do some, let's do five rapid fire tips I got from friends, sex therapists, articles, sexual health clinics on how to
越过了仅仅表现出尊重界限的底线。他们是在利用污名把自己摆在优越的位置上，这样的人不适合你去向其展现脆弱。如果是通过短信而且他们言辞非常严厉，你并不欠他们一场辩论。你可以直接停止回复。这听起来可能有点争议。教育每个人不是你的工作。你的心理健康远比证明自己不恶心、不肮脏或他们所说的任何词汇更有价值。我讨厌这些词，但你不需要成为那个改变他们观点的人。发给他们一些资源，发送统计数据，然后离开这个情境。好了，在总结之际，让我们快速回顾一下从朋友、性治疗师、文章和性健康诊所那里收集的5个快速锦囊，关于如何
date and live with an SDI. Number one, this is one I heard from a lot of friends, have a pre-written out script of info. If you're actively dating and you're trying to find your person, that barrier of having to tell somebody like we just said can be really overwhelming and honestly, exhausting when you're, you know, maybe seeing a few people, maybe getting rejected, having success in other ways. Save yourself the effort every time and save yourself the mental load or the emotional load of this discussion by just having a pre-typed message. I really like you, so I want to be honest. I have this. If you want to say I got it X amount of years ago, whatever, if you don't have to. It impacts me in this way. It impacts my life in this way, or not at all.
与STI约会并带病生活。第一点，这是我从很多朋友那里听到的，准备一份写好的信息脚本。如果你在积极约会并且试图找到对的人，就像我们刚才所说的那样，必须向某人坦白的障碍可能会让人不知所措，说实话，当你可能在跟几个人见面、可能遭受拒绝、或者在其他方面取得成功时，这会让人筋疲力尽。提前准备好一段打好的话，每次都能省去你的精力和这场讨论带来的心理负担或情感负担。我真的很喜欢你，所以我想坦白。我有这个。如果你想说我是X年前感染的，随便怎样，其实你也不必说得那么具体。它对我的影响是这样的。它对我的生活有这样的影响，或者根本没有影响。
The risk to you is this. If you want to keep seeing each other, this is maybe what is necessary. Number two on our rapid fire list, tell your friends if you haven't already. I'm going to be real. Your friends don't care, except to the extent that this is emotionally or physically hurting you. And if they do care beyond that, in a judgmental way, they are not your friends. Friendships like marriages, I think, should be through sickness and health, good times and bad times. This is included. This is one of those times. In general, like I just want to say, say every time a friend has told me, I have never thought anything other than what do you need from me? It's never been a moral judgment flowed across my mind. It just isn't a big deal for me.
对你的风险是这样的。如果你想继续交往，这可能是必要的。我们快速锦囊列表上的第二点，如果你还没告诉朋友，那就告诉他们吧。说实话，你的朋友根本不在乎，除非这在情感上或身体上伤害了你。如果他们在此之外还在意，并且带有评判态度，那他们就不是你的朋友。我认为友谊就像婚姻一样，应该风雨同舟、患难与共。这也包括在内。这就是那种时刻。总的来说，我只想说，每次当一个朋友告诉我这件事时，我脑子里从来没有产生过除了“你需要我做什么？”之外的想法。从来没有任何道德评判掠过我的脑海。对我来说这根本不是什么大事。
And I think the more educated we get, the more most people realize it's not a big deal. To the extent that they care about you and it's a big deal for you, but they still love you. you will also connect with so many other people that maybe are mutual friends or even your friends who have a similar experience and you will find so much kinship in just being like i'm not alone tip number three keep up with the latest science i'm going to quote dr ali carter here the meaning of safe sex changes every decade so you have to keep up every year they develop new strategies new methods new science new drugs you can live a full life now undoubtedly but I think there is so much more optimism coming out in this space I
而且我认为，我们受到的教育越多，大多数人就越会意识到这不是什么大事。尽管他们在乎你，而这对你来说是一件大事，但他们依然爱着你。你也会与许多其他人建立联系，他们可能是共同的朋友，甚至是你那些有过相似经历的朋友，你会发现一种巨大的归属感，那就是：我并不孤单。第三个锦囊，紧跟最新的科学。我在这里引用阿里·卡特（Ali Carter）博士的话：安全性行为的定义每十年都在改变，所以你必须每年都跟进。他们每年都在开发新策略、新方法、新科学、新药物。毫无疑问，你现在可以过上充实的生活，但我认为这个领域正涌现出越来越多的乐观情绪。我
actually saw this article that said sexual health research and medical research and sexual the sexual health space is one of the most optimistic places for research right now that's that's great news we're not trying to be like toxicly positive we're just trying to be informed and just yeah see the future for what it is with the most information tip number four obviously continue to practice safe sex always. Book tests every time you have a new partner or every three months. No matter what, even if you haven't had a new sexual partner, even if you have no symptoms, many SDIs never display symptoms until it's progressed. Chlamydia, for example,
实际上看到过这样一篇文章，上面说性健康研究、医学研究以及性健康领域是目前研究中最乐观的领域之一。这真是个好消息。我们并不是想盲目地强行乐观，我们只是想做到消息灵通，并且以最充分的信息去真实地看待未来。第四个锦囊，很明显，还是要坚持进行安全性行为。每次有了新伴侣或每三个月预约检测一次。无论如何，哪怕你没有新的性伴侣，哪怕你没有任何症状，许多性传播感染在病情恶化之前是从来不会显现症状的。例如衣原体感染，
especially in women, HPV is another one, same with herpes. You might not know until you have a flare-up. Consider it, like, if you are having regular sex, consider it like getting your haircut or your nails done, like integrate it into your routine as part of your hygiene and your health care. And finally, remember that the shame isn't yours to carry. People have been getting SDIs since human history began. It is as normal as childbirth, as heartbreak, as any illness. Society has mixed it up with morality in a way that is very, very painful, but so many people have been in your position and made it through the physical and emotional aspects of it.
特别是在女性中，人乳头瘤病毒（HPV）是另一种，疱疹也是如此。在你病情爆发之前，你可能根本无从知晓。把它想象成——如果你有规律的性生活，就像剪头发或做美甲一样，把它融入你的日常生活，作为你的个人卫生和医疗保健的一部分。最后，请记住，耻辱不应该由你来背负。自从人类历史开始以来，人们就一直感染性传播感染。它就像分娩、心碎或任何疾病一样正常。社会以一种非常、非常痛苦的方式将它与道德混为一谈，但有那么多人都曾处于你的位置，并挺过了它的生理和心理层面。
A diagnosis doesn't mean, again, this word doesn't mean you're dirty, makes you informed about your health and well-being, which lets you do the most adult thing, the most caring thing possible, which is to get treated, protect others, protect your health, and communicate it honestly. So I have a lot of love for the situation you're in right now. I hope the stories of people that I know who have been through this is comforting. if you don't have people in your life who are open to talking about it, I hope that you can take those stories and feel like those are your friends and you can be having those same chats with them
确诊并不意味着——再次强调，这个词并不意味着你肮脏，它意味着你对自己的健康和福祉有充分的了解，这能让你去做最成年、最有爱心的事情，那就是接受治疗，保护他人，保护你的健康，并诚实地进行沟通。所以我对你现在所处的境遇充满爱意。我希望我认识的那些经历过这一切的人的故事能带给你安慰。如果你的生活中没有那些愿意开诚布公地谈论这件事的人，我希望你能从这些故事中汲取力量，觉得那些人就是你的朋友，你可以和他们进行同样坦诚的交谈，
and feel completely safe with that and know that you are completely supported and never judged and that it's all going to be okay. I promise. Thank you to Libby Colbert for her research contributions to this episode. As always, she is amazing and she was a great help with this episode. Until next time, be safe, be kind, especially be gentle with yourself if this episode resonated with you at all. You have all my love and we will talk very, very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all?
并从中感到完全的安全，知道自己得到了完全的支持，绝不会被评判，一切都会好起来的。我向你保证。感谢利比·科尔伯特（Libby Colbert）为本期节目做出的研究贡献。一如既往，她太棒了，对本期节目的帮助极大。直到下次，注意安全，保持善良，尤其是如果这期节目在任何方面引起了你的共鸣，请对自己温柔一点。送上我全部的爱，我们很快就会再聊。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
欢迎收听《艰难成长的教训》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·加姆斯（Kear Games）。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极不安全、无法开展的坦诚对话，而你是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人披着一副盔甲？它向世界释放出的信号是：你可不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这个能力并不意味着你就必须这么做。请在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难成长的教训》。2%。这就是当自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strength. modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练以及在我们这个现代世界中培养韧性的科学法则。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终将成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。请在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。即TWO percent。当一群女性发现她们约会的竟然是同一个劣迹斑斑的骗子时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他一定会得到他应得的
deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Lookback at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we We survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year.
惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。请在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回看过去》（Lookback at it）播客中。对于1979年来说，那对我是一个重大的时刻。84年对我也很重要。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利希（Alex English）。每一期节目中，我们都会带你回到过去，剖析当时发生的事情，并尝试理清我们是如何与朋友、喜剧同行以及最喜欢的作家一起挺过来的。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代一样。那是一个疯狂的年代。那是一个疯狂的年代。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。请在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看过去》。这是一个IHeart播客。保证真人制作。本期节目暂无评论。点击转写中的任意句子即可发表评论。